authorities are warning residents and
guests in Lake Tahoe to secure their
exterior doors as a foot fondling
Intruder has been targeting the area
that's scary kind of like absurd and
ridiculous if he's just fondling feet so
if he ever gets arrested he could be
like what what am I guilty of I wanted
to care for someone's feet walking
around all day
we're getting tired we're getting tired
I'm trying to give him a massage he just
can't help himself officer please remove
your boots hey man you look tired once
you kick those boots off and get get him
away from me his voice is weirdly relax
come on man get those boots off before I
lick them you had a long time you had a
long day come on just a minute you had a
long day you only get those yeah get the
socks off and get those let me smell
those feet
oh that is hitting Sergeant
coming out